super un bonjour et merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors une
vidéo qui relance le débat sur l'article
24 du projet de loi sécurité globale les
images que l'on a découvert hier sont
elles un cas isolé ou est ce que vous
observez un regain de violence chez les
policiers
ce qu'on observe surtout c'est que
encore une fois on est une affaire de
violence policière dans laquelle les
images vidéo alors là c'est andy
vidéosurveillance mais en fait c'est la
vidéosurveillance du de la personne qui
est attaquée donc c'est des vidéos
personnelles qui prouve que ce que
disaient les policiers sur procès-verbal
s'avérer faux et en plus les cas
aujourd'hui en france et c'est le cas
notamment à lyon dans lé dossier qu'on
suit je pense à la sphère de cédric
jouve ya tout un tas d'affaires qui ont
été largement médiatisés ces derniers
temps où on est dans la même situation
les policiers donnent des déclarations
sur leurs procès verbaux et dans leurs
comptes rendus et les vidéos ensuite
viennent démontrer que ce qu'il disait
était strictement faut alors le problème
c'est que face à cette situation
malheureusement la justice continue tu
semblais croire la parole des policiers
dans ce genre de cas comme une parole
d'évangile c'est bien pour ça que la
nécessité des images de de police en
pleine action est absolument nécessaire
pour que les enquêtes puissent être
ouverte d'abord on voit le cas avec l
affaire qui a été que le publié hier
et puis s'être ensuite mené avec
suffisamment d'éléments de preuve
alors justement gérald darmanin qui a
parlé match inqualifiable
hier à charmer que les policiers ils
sont pour l'instant suspendu ils seront
révoqués si les faits sont confirmés ils
n'auront plus le droit de porter
l'uniforme des forces de l'ordre c'est
la réponse que vous attendiez
du ministre de l'intérieur encore une
fois on peut se poser la question et je
pense qu'on a assez vite la réponse que
se serait-il passé s'il n'y avait pas
d'image on aurait sûrement pas la tête
affligé du ministère de l'intérieur on
aurait sûrement pas toutes les
déclarations de politiques sur ces faits
on aurait quelqu'un qui aurait été
déférées en comparution immédiate pour
probablement rébellion voire violences
sur des forces de l'ordre et on en
serait resté là et c'est ça le quotidien
des personnes qui ont affaire à la
police aujourd'hui donc évidemment les
autorités sont bien obligés de faire
comme si c'était un fait divers
fantastique est absolument
extraordinaire en fait c'est juste un
fait divers qui s'accumulent à tous les
faits divers de ces derniers temps je
pense que la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'il
ya une vigilance forte des médias sur
cette question en particulier parce que
demain si l'article 24 et voter ils
seront en partie en partie empêché de
faire leur travail
donc voilà on est on est dans une
situation où les images sont au coeur
des procédures judiciaires elles sont au
coeur de la capacité à pouvoir prouver
les manquements des forces de l'ordre et
c'est bien ça la question l'essentiel
c'est est ce que demain ça pourra
continuer alors l'article 24 qui a déjà
été modifié on a appris que jean castex
instaurer une commission pour une
nouvelle écriture justement de cet
article controversé aujourd'hui est-ce
que c'est suffisant une règle du cri
tueur ou est ce qu'il faudrait tout
simplement le retirer du projet de loi
sécurité globale réécriture ça peut
vouloir tout dire et rien dire alors on
verra bien ce qui est certain c'est que
le contenu de cet article de disparaître
il est impossible d'accepter qu'on ait
un texte qui empêche
concrètement la prise d'image fait par
des journalistes ou par des personnes
diverses et variées depuis les
manifestations notamment mais pas que
prendre des images des policiers en
actions soit interdit on a beaucoup
discuté et on discute beaucoup de la
portée juridique exacte de ce texte les
défenseurs du texte 10 qu'il s'agira pas
d'une interdiction et les personnes qui
s'oppose à ce texte dont nous sommes
considère qu'il s'agira bien d'une
interdiction mais c'est pratique d'avoir
ce genre de discussion quand on est sur
un plateau télé où quand on est sur les
bancs de l'assemblée nationale
concrètement la police a fait respecter
la loi dans la rue et c'est face à elle
que demain il faudra
il faudra se trouver pour savoir et
débattre entre guillemets de la portée
exacte du texte on a identifié sur 95
des allégations de violences à lyon sur
ces deux dernières années que le
cinquième des blessures qui ont été
causés à des manifestants étaient sur
des personnes qui étaient en train de
prendre des images déjà la police est
extrêmement agressive y compris la vie
durant dix professionnels d'ailleurs
vis-à-vis des gens qui les prennent en
images en photo grand film donc qu'en
sera-t-il demain sur city ce texte de
loi passe peu importe la portée
juridique réel les policiers où ils ont
leurs ministres de l'intérieur qui leur
a dit il s'agit d'une d'une interdiction
de filmer s'agit d'une obligation de
flouter les visages des policiers donc
ils le prendront à la lettre et ils
seront évidemment beaucoup plus violents
vis-à-vis des gens qui essaieront de les
prendre en images
merci beaucoup lionel perrin d'avoir
répondu à nos questions j'aurais pas que
vous êtes membre du comité contre les
violences policières à lyon